next question uh from adam thoughts on
high sodium for strength sports
um this has become pretty popular um a
lot of people
going a little higher with their sodium
intake hoping for some performance
improvements the rda or the recommended
intake in the states last time i checked
i think was like to keep it under 2300
milligrams a day so under like 2.3 grams
a day seems very plausible uh and it's
very clear why that set hypertension is
prevalent uh some people are pretty salt
sensitive you know when salt or sodium
goes up in their diet blood pressure
tends to increase a little bit and so
you know the recommended intake is
largely focused on
trying to manage
hypertension rates in the segment of the
population that is a little bit
sensitive to dietary sodium
now
the rda is not necessarily for optimal
performance for athletes and that's
something we always have to consider
we do lose sodium when we sweat
so higher salt intakes may be tolerated
well by some athletes and in some cases
might actually be
necessary so not just well tolerated but
actually beneficial uh depending on you
know your rate of sweat sweat loss the
concentration of your sweat which does
vary
um
and so the reason that this is important
for athletes is because
sufficient sodium levels help us
maintain plasma volume uh help encourage
us to continue drinking fluids uh so
sometimes you'll see in sport nutrition
strategies they'll add some sodium to
the sports beverage not because you
necessarily need sodium replacement but
because they want you to continue having
the thirst response and continue
drinking more and more fluid throughout
the
doesn't it also just hydrate you a
little bit faster though yeah yeah it
does but but sometimes the uh
they'll specifically kind of highlight
uh that extra sodium i mean it
absolutely it does help hydrate you a
little bit more than just a water
solution so there are multi-faceted
benefits but uh for there's a lot of
athletes who will
dehydrate themselves because they just
don't feel like drinking water and so a
nice sports beverage with some sodium
and some sugar and things like that it
tastes good it encourages that thirst
response and the fact that it also
hydrates them better is like oh terrific
but we really just need them to keep
coming back for more cups of beverage
you know
so uh anyway
absolutely maintaining sufficient sodium
levels uh and drinking a sodium beverage
during uh particular types of exercise
can be a good strategy for uh replacing
the sodium that's lost from sweat
encouraging thirst response and more
fluid intake and maintaining hydration
but
this is particularly important when it
comes to
exercise that involves high sweat rates
so if you're lifting in a
climate-controlled gym
probably doesn't matter a ton depending
on how much you typically sweat and how
hot it is in the gym
um now if you're in like a you know if
it's like a ronnie coleman training
video from back in the day
uh texas right yeah so you're you know
in the middle of texas it's july he
trained at metroflex houston
yeah so if it's if it's july and houston
and there's no air conditioner
yeah
you're probably losing some sweat
probably losing some sodium
so some degree of replacement might
might be warranted there but when we
talk about the idea of sodium and
actually enhancing performance
the only studies where i've seen that
really happen is
performance of tasks in situations where
hydration status is truly threatening
performance so
if you're doing an endurance type
exercise that involves high cardiac
output it's in the heat it's prolonged
duration those are instances where you
might find a performance benefit if
you're comparing a water solution to a
solution with some degree of sodium in
it
now it is true mechanistically that
sodium plays a role in muscle
contraction
but
uh
we got to pause before we say therefore
more sodium more contraction very strong
the body has very robust mechanisms to
maintain stability within a certain
range when it comes to to blood sodium
levels
and that's because sodium and potassium
are
very important uh so that that's not the
type of thing that your body likes to
lose track of
um
and you know of course with
really substantial with great enough
sodium losses at some point those
mechanisms could be unable to maintain
appropriate levels of sodium and
potassium but well i mean the the same
uh
the same sodium and potassium related uh
like mechanisms of um like muscle
membrane depolarization
that's the same thing that goes on with
like nerve depolarization yeah so
as long as your nerves work your muscles
are probably going to work
just fine yeah you should at least like
with regards to to electrolyte balance
yeah you do want your nerves working
yeah
always correct when possible um
so like you know there was a study by
the general point here is if your sodium
levels in your blood are getting low
enough that muscle contraction is being
impacted
you are screwed yeah that is not a good
spot to be
uh so it's not that you know the lifter
i mean
i don't even know that you would get
there this is this is complete
speculation i haven't thought about it
that much
but uh i mean like
endurance athletes that die of
hyponatremia are
aren't they generally still running when
their brain swells up and they die
i don't know i mean i i
i think their muscles are still
functioning
well enough to keep them moving
while their sodium levels are
from a nervous system perspective
already dangerously dangerously low yeah
so i i kind of think that
uh if sodium levels are already low
enough
that they're affecting muscle
contractility
you got a big [ __ ] problem on your
hands yeah and
you probably will have noticed it
already because you'll
i mean you'll be getting delirious yeah
so i did find a study looking at this uh
title was impact of hyponatremia on
nerve conduction and muscle strength by
van der geinst
and colleagues
chronic mild to moderate hyponatremia
like clinical hyponatremia
did not have an impact on muscle
strength within that study and these
were not particularly healthy folks
within this study um so
the the overall
conclusion here
uh
it's not that you know taking a big
spoonful of sodium is going to
supercharge your workout or anything
like that
that would not be an accurate
representation of the data that i've
seen personally always always open to
reviewing new studies that i may not be
aware of of course
but the general idea is you just want to
keep your your sodium and potassium
levels within
uh healthy viable ranges and it usually
doesn't take a tremendous amount of
effort to do that if you are
exercising and losing a lot of sweat and
your sweat has particularly high
concentrations of sodium a little bit of
sodium replacement might not be a
terrible idea
but i probably don't need a super
nuanced uh
deliberate strategy to do any type of
sodium loading for performance or
anything like that